Copy on a Tuesday.
Wait,
who are you?
I'm waiting for winter.
I know who you are.
What are you doing in my video?
My video.
This is clearly every week and you're
infringing upon it.
If you don't remove yourself at one
point I will be forced to call youtube
security.
Don't don't cut that out.
They have me on hold.
Me Too.
I don't want.
Here's a phenomenon you might be
familiar with to demonstrate.
I'm going to enlist the help of Craig
Benzie.
Otherwise known as.
That's great.
Sitting at his desk editing one of his
videos.
It's late.
He's getting tired.
Anything's another cup of coffee is in
order,
so he.
He goes into the kitchen,
pours himself a cup and realizes that he
has to go into the time machine room
because he needs to get the.
Wait a second.
What did he need?
He can't seem to remember.
The first impulse is to go back to the
kitchen.
Stand by the coffee machine that Oh yes,
yes,
yes.
Now we remember he needed the.
I'm sure you've all had this experience
before,
the experience of arriving somewhere
only to realize that you've forgotten
what you went through to do.
Why does this happen?
Well,
last year,
neurological researchers from Notre Dame
published an article called why walking
through doorways causes,
forget it's a.
it's a good title,
and their thesis is that at all times
our brains are operating within
something called an event model,
a collection of memories relevant to the
current activity,
walking through a doorway can
unintentionally purge this model because
whatever was happening in the old room
is less likely to be relevant.
Now that you've changed venues,
brains do this to us well because
normally event models operate
beautifully.
It would be impossible to keep all of
our memories at the fore of our mind,
so our brain's employee,
this incredible mechanism to keep all
the relevant memories within reach and
event modeled as being built in your
brain right now.
Yes,
but I'd like to make a larger point here
if I met you.
See,
this whole business with the vent models
gives us a great universally
recognizable example of the fact that
our brains are busy every moment with
activities of which were not aware.
In fact,
before we are aware of any one thing
that we do,
there are a series of neurological
activities proceeding it.
Benjamin Libet of pioneering scientists
in the field of human consciousness
famously proved that activity in the
brain can be measured some 300
milliseconds before the person feels
that he has decided to move today with
the use of Mri.
That estimate has been extended to
something like six seconds.
How should this be extrapolated in
regard to a concept we all know as
freewill freewill is at the basis of
nearly all our belief systems,
it founds not only moral considerations,
but legal ones.
The concepts of incarceration in
retribution are bound up with
responsibility which is bound up with
free choice,
but as we've seen our choices proceed
from neural activity of which we are,
again,
not aware,
so does does this mean for example,
that a murderer complete the defense?
My brain made me do it.
Einstein didn't believe in freewill yet,
he still believed that murderer should
be put in jail.
Why?
Well,
because they're dangerous.
The fact that neural activity proceeds
and determines our choices doesn't mean
that the murderer can separate the part
of himself which is responsible for the
act of murder.
We are choosing all the time.
We can't help it even with the knowledge
that we can't choose what we choose.
We can't stop choosing.
You can sit there and do nothing but
doing nothing is itself a choice and one
that gets harder with every second.
Eventually you'll decide that this
business of doing nothing is a waste of
your time and you'll choose to get up.
So maybe we should imagine our
consciousness as something like a river
choice exists as a part of that river,
but some ways downstream from the source
and farther downstream from the choice
is the action and the action has real
consequences in the world around you and
those consequences.
To the extent that you're around a
witness them have an effect on the river
as a whole.
See that the mysterious source of the
river for the most part is not acting
against you.
It's not an external consciousness and
it's not a random decision generator.
It acts in harmony with your beliefs and
ideals,
with what makes you happy and sad and
it's informed by the consequences of
your choices and by the choices of those
around you and by the environment in
which you live and grow.
There is an experiential disconnect here
which is hard to overcome.
When you look back over your day,
your month,
your life,
you feel as if you were the author of
your choices,
you feel as if you chose this road as
opposed to that road and that over time,
this free decider,
what you call I has built its own
identity.
The problem is that this is impossible
to reconcile with the fact that at every
moment of your life you're being
informed by unconscious processes like
say event models.
Free will is an illusion.
It's difficult to accept.
It's difficult for me to accept that my
consciousness is telling me a story
about myself,
which isn't true,
but I can know it despite my feelings
and I can remind myself of it when I
take myself too seriously or I'm too
hard on myself for mistakes and maybe in
endeavoring to understand this part of
me,
I can become more empathetic toward
those who like me,
like all of us try so desperately hard
to control their lives and trip up in
the most spectacular ways.
Yes.
I remember what I was supposed to do,
what I have to save the world from this
nuclear explosion by setting the time
machine.
Oh Wow.